THE WILL COME TO ORDER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
RATHER G. ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKESPEAR
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. CORTEZ.
GLI. THANK GOD RAO. EDMUND.
BLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES. LAYERED LIMÓN
MAGUIRE. MENJIVAR. MEN. NEWMAN.
WHEN NELO A CBO. IDEA.
ARGENTINO. ROTH. RUBIO. THEY ARE
TO SKINNER. SMALL QUAVERS STERN.
HUMBERG W. WEINER. WILK.
MEMBERS. GOOD AFTERNOON,
EVERYONE A QUORUM IS PRESENCE.
LIKE TO INVITE THE MEMBERS AND
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR NILO. AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
SENATOR NEO THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. FOR THE EXPANDING
GRANDEUR OF CREATION WE GIVE
THANKS THIS DAY. FOR THIS
FRAGILE PLANET EARTH. WE GIVE
THANKS THIS DAY. FOR THE JOY OF
HUMAN LIFE, ITS WONDERS AND
SURPRISES WE GIVE THANKS THIS
DAY. FOR OUR HUMAN COMMUNITY ARE
ONENESS TRANSCENDING ALL
SEPARATION WE GIVE THANKS THIS
DAY. FOR FAITH WITHOUT
FANATICISM FOR UNDERSTANDING OF
VIEWS NOT SHARED. WE GIVE THANKS
THIS DAY. FOR ALL WHO HAVE LÀ
LABORED AND SUFFERED FOR A
FAIRER WORLD. WE GIVE THANKS TO
THIS DAY. FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO
CHANGE AND GROW TO AFFIRM AND
CHOOSE. WE GIVE THANKS THIS DAY.
WE PRAY THAT WE MAY LIVE NOT BY
OUR FEARS. BUT BY OUR HOPES NOT
BY OUR WORDS. BUT BY OUR DEEDS.
AMEN. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NIELSEN. YOU LOVE. MEMBERS.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN AT PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO INTRODUCE THAT 9 2024,
IRVINE FOUNDATION LEADERSHIP
AWARDEES. I DON'T WANNA
RECOGNIZE PRO TEM MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR PRESIDENT, AND
GOOD AFTERNOON, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO RECOGNIZE SEVERAL
OUTSTANDING CALIFORNIANS THAT
RECEIVED THIS YEAR'S JAMES
IRVINE FOUNDATION LEADERSHIP
AWARD FOR THEIR INNOVATIVE AND
EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS CAN LEAD TO
OUR STATE'S MOST PRESSING
CHALLENGES. FROM HUNDREDS OF
NOMINATIONS. THE IRVINE
FOUNDATION SELECTED NINE
EXTRAORDINARY LEADERS FROM SIX
ORGANIZATIONS TO RECEIVE THIS
PRESTIGIOUS LEADERSHIP AWARD.
THIS IS A DIVERSE GROUP. DESERVE
DIVERSE GROUP OF GRASSROOTS
HEROES WHO ARE IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS AND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE. THEY'RE
TACKLING ISSUES SUCH AS OUR
TEACHER SHORTAGE A API HATE OUR
YOUTH JUSTICE SYSTEM REFORM,
WORKING TO EXPAND COLLEGE ACCESS
AND, OF COURSE, EXPANDED
RESOURCES FOR THE L GB Tð Q
COMMUNITY. THESE AWARDEES ARE A
SHINING LIGHT. AND PROMISING NEW
WAYS TO UPLIFT UNDER-RESOURCED
COMMUNITIES AND ARE LAYING THE
GROUNDWORK FOR A MORE PROSPEROUS
SUSTAINABLE CALIFORNIA. AND
WE'RE EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO
HONOR THEM HERE TODAY AND WE
WANT TO OFFER THEM OUR HEARTFELT
CONGRATULATIONS. SO LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO KICK OFF THIS
EXTRAORDINARY CEREMONY IF WE
COULD PLEASE TURN THE FLOOR OVER
MR PRESIDENT TO SENATOR BECKER
TO BE ABLE TO LEAD US OFF.
SENATOR BECKER AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. WELL, THANK YOU.
PRO TEM MCGUIRE. IT'S MY HONOR
TO INTRODUCE TWO LEADERS.
ELIZABETH BAHAM AND HECTOR
CAMACHO JUNIOR WHO ARE RECEIVING
THIS AWARD FOR THEIR PIONEERING
WORK AT REACH UNIVERSITY TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S TEACHER
SHORTAGE. IN OUR STATE. WE ARE
FACING A TEACHER SHORTAGE A
CRISIS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, WITH
10,000 VACANCIES AND 20% OF THE
WORKFORCE PLANNING TO LEAVE IN
THE NEXT THREE YEARS. THIS
UNDERMINES THE QUALITY OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM PUTS OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM REALLY AT
RISK AND OUR FUTURE AS A STATE.
HAVE REACHED UNIVERSITY.
ELIZABETH AND HECTOR TACKLE THIS
ISSUE HEAD ON. PROVIDING ON THE
JOB DEGREE AND CREDENTIAL
PROGRAMS FOR ASPIRING TEACHERS.
SO FOR ANYONE AT A AT THE SCHOOL
, UH MANY OF THEM ARE ALREADY
WORKING THE SCHOOL'S AIDES OR
OTHER NON TEACHING ROLES.
THEY'RE MAKING THE PATH TO COME
AND TEACH HER MORE AFFORDABLE.
MORE ATTAINABLE BY REMOVING THE
FINANCIAL AND TIME CONSTRAINTS.
ENRICHING THE LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR STUDENTS BY
PROVIDING WITH TEACHERS WHO ARE
ALREADY PART OF THE COMMUNITY
THERE AT THAT SCHOOL. THIS WORK
OFFERS A BEACON OF HOPE AND A
MODEL. HOW WE CAN MAKE THE
PATHWAY TO TEACHING MORE
ACCESSIBLE. MORE EQUITABLE AND
MORE REFLECTIVE OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE UH, STUDENT BODY AND
I'LL SAY POINT OF PRIVILEGE. UH
ESPECIALLY WITH MR CAMACHO.
WE'VE WORKED FOR MANY YEARS. UM
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL, UH, AND
EDUCATION AND HIS WORK AS THE,
UH, ON THE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND SAN MATEO COUNTY.
SO, MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING ELIZABETH BAHE AND
HECTOR CAMACHO, JUNIOR OF RE
UNIVERSITY. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING
TO DO INDIVIDUAL PICTURES WITH
THE SENATORS AND THE AND THE
AWARDEES FIRST, AND AT THE END
OF THE WHOLE CEREMONY, WE'LL DO
A GROUP PICTURE.
ALL RIGHT. CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU BOTH. WE NOW LIKE TO INVITE
SENATOR SKINNER TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AND I HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
TRANSFORMATIVE WORK OF FRANKIE
GUZMAN. A LEADER WHO EMBODIES
THE SPIRIT OF RESILIENCE,
REDEMPTION AND UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO YOUTH JUSTICE
REFORM. AS A LEADER OF THE YOUTH
JUSTICE PROGRAM OR THE LEADER OF
THE YOUTH JUSTICE PROGRAM AT THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW,
FRANKIE IS ADVOCATING FOR A
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT IS MORE
REHABILITATIVE THAN PUNITIVE,
AND THAT SEES THE POTENTIAL IN
EVERY YOUNG PERSON RATHER THAN
THEIR WORST MISTAKE BY MENTORING
YOUTH AND INCLUDING THEM IN
REFORM CAMPAIGNS AND DECISION
MAKING PROCESSES. FRANKIE AND
POWERS THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
ENSURES THAT THE SYSTEM REFLECTS
THE NEEDS AND REALITIES OF THOSE
THAT IT SERVES. HIS ADVOCACY HAS
LED TO THE SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATIVE ACHIEVEMENTS,
INCLUDING HIS PIVOTAL ROLE IN
THE PASSAGE OF PROP 57, WHICH
FUNDAMENTALLY SHIFTED THE
LANDSCAPE FOR YOUTH JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA. FRANKIE'S RELENTLESS
PURSUIT OF JUSTICE AND EQUITY,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE MOST
MARGINALIZED AMONG US SERVES AS
AN INSPIRATION AND A CALL TO
ACTION FOR ALL OF US, SO MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
FRANKIE GUZMAN OF THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
WE'D LIKE TO NEXT INVITE SENATOR
DIAZO TO COME TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK FOR PURPOSES OF
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. MEMBERS I HAVE THE
DISTINCT HONOR OF INTRODUCING TO
LEADERSHIP AWARD RECIPIENTS. THE
FIRST LEADER IS MASHA KULKARNI,
WHO IS RECOGNIZED FOR HER
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS HATE AND
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES IN LOS ANGELES, AND
THROUGHOUT AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA
. MANU'S LEADERSHIP AT THE A API
EQUITY ALLIANCE AND GUIDANCE AS
CO-FOUNDER OF STOP A API HATE
HAS GROWN BOTH ORGANIZATIONS TO
POWERFUL FORCES FOR CHANGE THAT
LEVERAGE DATA COLLECTION, POLICY
, ADVOCACY AND COMMUNITY
MOBILIZATION TO SHED LIGHT ON
THE INJUSTICES A API COMMUNITIES
FACE. HER COALITION PARTNERS
HAVE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT OF
CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCACY SECURING
MAJOR WINS. RECENTLY THE
COALITION JOINED WITH THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS TO CHAMPION A HISTORIC
$166 MILLION STATE INVESTMENT IN
OUR A API COMMUNITIES, SECURING
FUNDING DEDICATED TO HATE
PREVENTION AND SUPPORT FOR
VICTIMS. HER WORK WITH STOP A
API HATE HAS PROVIDED A PLATFORM
FOR THOUSANDS TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES AND DRIVE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION TO ADDRESS
HATE CRIMES AND HARASS AND
HARASSMENT. HER WORK CHAMPIONS.
THE RIGHTS OF A API COMMUNITIES
SERVES AS A TESTAMENT TO THE
IMPACT OF DEDICATED LEADERSHIP
AND THE PURSUIT OF A JUST
SOCIETY. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN CELEBRATING MANJUSHA KULKARNI
OF A API EQUITY ALLIANCE AND
STOP A API HATE. LET'S CELEBRATE
VISIONARY, THE VISIONARY
LEADERSHIP OF MICHELLE SIQUEIROS
, WHO I HAVE KNOWN FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS AS SHE DID THIS
EXTRAORDINARY WORK. AS PRESIDENT
OF CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. MICHELLE IS A
CHAMPION FOR COLLEGE
ACCESSIBILITY AND STUDENT
SUCCESS. WE KNOW THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS, INCLUDING LATINO,
BLACK AND FIRST GEN. STUDENTS
ARE UNDERREPRESENTED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. THIS IS LARGELY DUE
TO SOCIO-ECONOMIC BARRIERS AND
UNEQUAL ACCESS TO COLLEGE
PREPARATION. UNDER MICHELLE'S
LEADERSHIP, THE CAMPAIGN HAS
FACILITATED SIGNIFICANT
ADVANCEMENTS IN EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY FROM ADVOCATING FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A SEAMLESS
TRANSFER BETWEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE èC S¼ U SYSTEM
TO LEADING THE CHARGE AGAINST
THE USE OF STANDARDIZED TESTING
IN UNIVERSITY ADMISSIONS. HER
WORK ILLUMINATES THE PATH
FORWARD AND CALLS ON EACH OF US
TO CONTRIBUTE TO A FUTURE WHERE
EVERY STUDENT REGARDLESS OF
THEIR BACKGROUND, CAN PURSUE
HIGHER. AND ACHIEVE THEIR
FULLEST POTENTIAL. LET'S REWARD
THEM FOR DOING THE HARD WORK
MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING MICHELLE SROS OF
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY.
WE NEXT WANT TO INVITE SENATOR
HURTADO TO THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
DESK FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION OF THE NEXT
AWARDEES. SENATOR HURTADO. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. IT IS MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE TWO LEADERS FROM MY
DISTRICT, BRIAN PAUL AND NICK
VARGAS. THEY ARE THE CO-FOUNDERS
OF THE SOURCE. L GB Tð Q PLUS
CENTER IN VISALIA. BRIAN AND
NICK HAVE CREATED A SPACE FOR
THE L GB Tð Q PLUS COMMUNITY AND
HAVE IGNITED A MOVEMENT TOWARDS
UNDERSTANDING, ACCEPTANCE AND
INCLUSION IN A WAY THAT LEADS TO
GREATER ADVOCACY AND
REPRESENTATION. AND JUST EIGHT
YEARS THEY HAVE BUILT THE
LARGEST LGL GB Tð Q PLUS CENTER
BETWEEN LOS ANGELES AND
SACRAMENTO. LAST YEAR ALONE,
THEY SERVED ROUGHLY 24,000
INDIVIDUALS. THEIR EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
FACED IN RURAL AREAS,
PARTICULARLY AROUND HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND ACCESS TO
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CARE ARE
GROUNDBREAKING. THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A CLINIC TO
SERVE PEOPLE LIVING WITH HÌ. I
VÆ IS A CRITICAL STEP FORWARD IN
HEALTH CARE ACCESSIBILITY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. AS WE FACE A
RISE IN ANTI L, GB Tð Q
LEGISLATION AND OTHER STATES AND
AN INCREASE IN TARGETED HATE
CRIMES. THE WORK OF THE SOURCE
IS MORE CRUCIAL NOW THAN EVER
BEFORE. THANK YOU, BRIAN AND
NICK FOR YOUR DEDICATION AND TO
CREATING A SAFE, INCLUSIVE
ENVIRONMENT THAT CELEBRATES
DIVERSITY AND FOSTERS HOPE. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOUR
CONTINUED EFFORTS WILL FURTHER
SHAPE OUR COMMUNITY IN THE YEARS
TO COME. COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN
ME IN CELEBRATING BRIAN PO AND
NICK VARGAS.
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE SENATOR
ATKINS TO THE MAJORITY LEADER'S
DESK FOR PURPOSES OF
PRESENTATION. ATKINS THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES. I HAVE
THE HONOR OF WELCOMING TWO OF
OUR FINAL 2024 IRVINE AWARD
RECIPIENTS TODAY, SO PLEASE
ALLOW ME TO INTRODUCE BLANCA
MELENDREZ AND AMINA SHAQ
MOHAMMED. THESE INCREDIBLE
INSPIRING LEADERS ARE ADVANCING
HEALTH EQUITY THROUGH
COLLABORATIVE COMMUNITY LED
INITIATIVES. BLANCA AND AMINA'S
IMMIGRANT BACKGROUNDS GIVE THEM
UNIQUE INSIGHTS INTO THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY NEWCOMERS TO
OUR STATE, AND THEIR SOLUTIONS
RESONATE DEEPLY WITH THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE. AT
THE UC SAN DIEGO CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH, BLANCA AND
AMINA CHAMPION A COMMUNITY LED
TRANSFORMATIVE MODEL OR
TRANSFORMATION MODEL, ALSO
TRANSFORMATIVE THAT ELEVATES
COMMUNITY DESIGN SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. THIS MODEL REFLECTS
THEIR BELIEF THAT THOSE MOST
AFFECTED BY HEALTH DISPARITIES
ARE BEST POSITIONED TO IDENTIFY
EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS. THEIR WORK
WITH THE S¼ CENTERS REFUGEE
HEALTH UNIT HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN CREATING A
SUPPORT SYSTEM FOR REFUGEE
FAMILIES, WHICH INCLUDES THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE SAN DIEGO
REFUGEE COMMUNITIES COALITION.
THE COALITION HAS ACHIEVED
SUCCESS THROUGH COLLABORATION,
BRINGING TOGETHER 12 ETHNIC
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
ENHANCE THE WELL BEING OF
REFUGEES THROUGH UNIFIED
PROGRAMMING AND FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES. TO DATE, THEIR
WORK HAS ACTIVATED $80 MILLION
FOR COMMUNITY LED INITIATIVES
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
PROGRAMS THAT DIRECTLY BENEFIT
MORE THAN 40,000 HOUSEHOLDS
MONTHLY. THEY HAVE BUILT A
FRAMEWORK NOT JUST FOR HEALTH
INTERVENTION, BUT FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT, COLLABORATION AND
RESILIENCE FOR THEIR VISIONARY
WORK TO ENSURE A HEALTHIER, MORE
EQUITABLE FUTURE. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. I ASK THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING BLANCA
AND AMINA FROM THE U èC SAN
DIEGO CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
HEALTH.
TO CONCLUDE OUR CEREMONY TODAY.
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE SENATE
MINORITY LEADER SENATOR JONES TO
SHARE HIS THOUGHTS. THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. IT'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE HONOR TODAY TO
CELEBRATE THE REMARKABLE
ACHIEVEMENTS OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS. EACH ORGANIZATION
HAS DEDICATED ITS TIME TO A
COMMUNITY FOCUSED LEADERSHIP
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THE
CRITICAL ISSUES THAT ARE FACING
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS, THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR ENTIRE
STATE. LET'S ALL TAKE
INSPIRATION FROM THESE
ORGANIZATIONS AND GO BACK TO OUR
OWN DISTRICTS WITH THE CONTINUED
SPIRIT TO MAKE CALIFORNIA A
BETTER PLACE FOR EVERYONE. THANK
YOU, EVERYONE FOR JOINING US IN
THIS CELEBRATION, LET'S GIVE ONE
MORE ROUND OF APPLAUSE TO THE
2024 JAMES IRVINE FOUNDATION
LEADERSHIP AWARD RECIPIENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO INVITE ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TO JOIN
THE AWARDEES FOR A GROUP PHOTO?
IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU ALL.
CONTINUING ON TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. WE'D LIKE TO NOW
RECOGNIZE SENATOR CORTESE AT THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. SENATOR
CORTESE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
SENATORS IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
RECOGNIZE WEST VALLEY COMMUNITY
SERVICES, A NONPROFIT SERVING
THE COMMUNITIES OF WEST SAN JOSE
, CUPERTINO, VASCARI, MONTESSORI
AND SARATOGA. AND IF YOU'RE
WONDERING, THAT'S WHAT WE CALL
THE WEST VALLEY SIDE OF
SENATE-DISTRICT 15 OF THE NON
SAN JOSE PORTION FOUNDED IN 1970
, THREE WEST VALLEY COMMUNITY
SERVICES, FIGHTS, HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS BY PROVIDING A
CONTINUUM OF BASIC NEEDS FOR THE
WEST VALLEY POPULATION. THEIR
SERVICES ENCOMPASS A RANGE OF
OFFERINGS, INCLUDING AN IN-HOUSE
FOOD MARKET, A MOBILE FOOD
MARKET, HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE.
ADDITIONALLY THEY PROVIDE CASE
MANAGEMENT AND SPECIAL PROGRAMS
SUCH AS BACK TO SCHOOL AND
HOLIDAY INITIATIVES TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES. EACH YEAR. THIS
ORGANIZATION DISTRIBUTES OVER
£800,000 OF FOOD TO PEOPLE IN
NEED IN THE WEST VALLEY OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. THEY OWN AND
OPERATE TWO APARTMENT COMPLEXES,
AND THESE COMPLEXES OFFER
PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS FOR
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES, LED BY THE VALUES OF
COMPASSION, DIGNITY, INTEGRITY,
SERVICE AND DIVERSITY. THE
ORGANIZATION HAS POSITIVELY
IMPACTED THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
ABOUT 22,000 PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
POVERTY AGAIN IN THE WEST VALLEY
PORTION OF SENATE-DISTRICT 15.
I'D LIKE TO COMMEND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE ORGANIZATIONS,
UH, INCLUDING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. SUE JAFFA IK VENKAT
TRÊN, UH, SUJATHA HAS BEEN WITH
WEST VALLEY COMMUNITY SERVICES
SINCE 2008 AND SHE HAS 25 YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE, UM, IN THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR. HERE TODAY IS
A GROUP OF FOLKS WITH HER, UH
INCLUDING, UH, MY GOOD FRIEND
AND FORMER SAN JOSE CITY
COUNCILMAN CHAPPY JONES, WHO IS
THE VICE MAYOR OF THE CITY JUST
RECENTLY, UH, BEFORE LEAVING THE
COUNCIL AND ALSO COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER JOCELYN ARES AND
ASSISTANT MANAGER OF PUBLIC
POLICY AND ADVOCACY PROGRAM,
CASSANDRA MAA. IN ADDITION, OUR
OUR OTHER BOARD MEMBERS THAT
HAVE JOINED TODAY AS PART OF THE
CEREMONY. I WILL TELL YOU THAT
SINCE MY DAYS, UH AS A CITY VICE
MAYOR AND THEN AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR FOR A DOZEN YEARS,
UH, THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPACTFUL ORGANIZATIONS AND
CONTINUES TO BE, OF COURSE,
RIGHT THROUGH THE PANDEMIC. THEY
DID NOT MISS A STEP. AND THEY
HAVE CONTINUED THEIR GOOD WORK.
I WOULD ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
GIVING, UH, THEM. UM. AGREEING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF ALL THEIR
MEANINGFUL SERVICE AND
DEDICATION TO THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. RELATIONS. WELCOME TO
THE SENATE.
I'D LIKE TO REMIND SENATORS THAT
THE CONVERSATIONS ON THE FLOOR
CAN BE A LITTLE DISTRACTING. WE
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE YOU TO GO
TO THE BACK OF THE ROOM IF YOU
NEED TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
DURING THESE PRESENTATIONS.
LIKE TO NOW, UH. RECOGNIZE
SENATOR JONES AS THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. IT'S A
GREAT HONOR FOR ME THIS
AFTERNOON TO, UH, RISE AND
RECOGNIZE PAULETTE DONNELLAN.
FROM SENATE-DISTRICT 40 FOR
WINNING THE DEPARTMENT. FISH AND
WILDLIFE WILDLIFE PHOTO OF THE
YEAR AWARD WHICH CAN YOU CAN BE
SEEN HERE OF FOUR JUVENILE
BURROWING OWLS. JOINING HER ON
THE FLOOR TODAY ARE TWO MEMBERS
OF HER FAMILY, LAURA DUNELLEN
AND BRITTANY LINDER, AS WELL AS
ERICA FISK SANDERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. AND THE GALLERY
ARE REPRESENTATIVES FROM OUTDOOR
CALIFORNIA WATCHABLE WILDLIFE
AND THE SIERRA NEVADA
CONSERVANCY. PAULETTE'S WINNING
IMAGE WAS CAPTURED IN THE SUNNY
BONO, SALTON SEA NATIONAL
WILDLIFE RESERVE AND SHOWCASES
THE BEAUTIFUL NATURE. WE ARE ALL
BLESSED TO ENJOY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. COLLEAGUES PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
PAULETTE ON THIS PRESTIGIOUS
HONOR OF THE, UH, STATEWIDE
PHOTO AWARD RECOGNITION. THANK
YOU.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I JUST WANT TO. I
FORGOT TO MENTION THAT WE DO
HAVE A RESOLUTION FOR PAULETTE.
WHICH YOU ALL, UH, SAW, BUT THE
PHOTOS? UH PAULETTE HAS
ANNOUNCED TODAY THAT I WILL HAVE
THE HONOR OF DISPLAYING THIS IN
MY CAPITOL OFFICE FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME. SO ANYBODY THAT WANTS
TO COME SEE IT? UH, UNTIL WE
RETURN IT BACK TO HER, OUR
WELCOME TO COME AND, UH, LOOK AT
THE DISPLAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, SENATOR JONES.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
ON TO PRIVILEGES OF FLORIDA, BUT
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE ALL THE
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR TO TAKE
THEIR SEATS. IF THERE'S A
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD, PLEASE
TAKE IT OUTSIDE THE SENATE BACK
OF THE SENATE CHAMBERS. ALL THE
SENATORS PLEASE TAKE THEIR THEIR
SEATS, PLEASE. CONTINUING WITH
PRIVILEGES THE FLOOR WE'D LIKE
TO INVITE SENATOR BRADFORD TO
MAKE A PRESENTATION TODAY.
SENATOR BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
IT IS TRULY MY HONOR AND
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE 18 AMAZING
BUSINESSES THAT WE ARE HONORING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BLOCK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AT THIS MORNING'S BLACK
BUSINESS BRUNCH BUSINESSES THAT
RANGE FROM PRIOR TO THE OLDEST
BLACK MORTUARY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WOODS AND
VALENTINE, LOCATED IN PASADENA
TO AMAZING BARBECUE WITH
WOODY'S. IT'S AN INSTITUTION IN
L A OR THE SAL'S GUMBO AND LONG
BEACH OR THE OTIS. BLACK
DISTRIBUTOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. A BEER DISTRIBUTOR.
UH B¢O, CHAMP DISTRIBUTORS AND
LOS ANGELES NOW LOCATED IN
COMPTON. THESE BUSINESS LEADERS
HAVE BEEN CHOSEN BY MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AGAIN, ALONG WITH THE
BLOCK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE FOR
THEIR COMMITMENT AND SERVICE AND
PROFESSIONALISM. THE ANNUAL
BLACK BUSINESS BRUNCH PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO COME
TOGETHER TO RECOGNIZE AND HONOR
BLACK OWNED BUSINESSES AND ALL
ALLIES CREATING JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITIES. CLOSING THE
RACIAL WEALTH GAP IN EMPOWERING
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR
THE POSITIVE IMPACT THAT YOU'VE
HAD ON YOUR COMMUNITIES AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I WOULD ASK
ALL THOSE BUSINESS OWNERS WHO
ARE HERE TODAY TO STAND UP IN
THE GALLERY, SO THIS BODY CAN
RECOGNIZE YOU AND GIVE YOU A
ROUND OF APPLAUSE WELCOME THEM
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE CENTER.
WELCOME. GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE
AND CONGRATULATIONS. NEXT. WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR, SENATOR
NEWMAN. AND. SENATOR NEWMAN. UM
OH, OH, IT'S F. YEAH. YEAH I. I
SEE. WE'RE GONNA DO THAT LATER
ON IN THE AGENDA. SO SORRY ABOUT
THAT, SENATOR NEWMAN. ALL RIGHT,
THAT, UH, THAT CONCLUDES OUR
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR, SEEING
NÓ OTHER MICROPHONES UP. OK
WE'RE GONNA MOVE NEXT TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR.
THEY'LL BE DEEMED RED MESSAGES
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED READ IN AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED UNDER MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THE SENATE JOURNAL
FOR FEBRUARY 1ST 2024 THROUGH
FEBRUARY 8TH 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. WE'RE GONNA MOVE
NEXT TO INTRODUCTIONS AND FIRST
READING OF BILLS. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ BILL 1065 166 1 67 1
68 1069 1070 1071 11TH READING
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
FIRST STEP IS SECOND READING.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. CYNIC.
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 99. VERY
GOOD. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO SENATE THIRD READING. WE
GOING TO DO THREE BILLS UNDER
THIRD READING TODAY MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX, FOLLOWED BY
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AND NINE.
WILL BEGIN FIRST WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX S¼ R 54 OF THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ IN A
RESOLUTION 54 BY SENATOR MIN
RELATIVE TO THE LUNAR NEW YEAR,
SENATOR MAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
MOI. UH GONG HE FAT CHOI HER HER
MONEY, BUT A SALE UH, THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT, MEMBERS HAPPY
LUNAR NEW YEAR AND SO ON BEHALF
OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. I'M SO PLEASED TO
PRESENT S¼ R 54, WHICH
RECOGNIZES LUNAR NEW YEAR, WHICH
BEGAN ON FEBRUARY 10TH AND WILL
END ON FEBRUARY 24TH. TO MANY
AMERICANS OF ASIAN DESCENT,
LUNAR NEW YEAR IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT HOLIDAYS OF THE
YEAR. IT REPRESENTS LONG
STANDING CULTURAL TRADITIONS AND
WELCOMES LUCK AND PROSPERITY.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE LUNAR NEW
YEAR ALONGSIDE THE 2.5 MILLION
CHINESE, KOREAN, VIETNAMESE AND
LEAN RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
THAT OBSERVED THIS HOLIDAY.
THANKS TO MANY OF YOU,
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST STATE
IN THE NATION TO RECOGNIZE LUNAR
NEW YEAR AS AN OFFICIAL STATE
HOLIDAY. 2024 IS THE YEAR THE
DRAGON, AN ANIMAL THAT
REPRESENTS STRENGTH, BRAVERY AND
INNOVATION, AND I WAS ACTUALLY
BORN IN THE YEAR OF THE DRAGON A
FEW CYCLES AGO. MORE
SPECIFICALLY, THIS YEAR IS THE
YEAR OF THE WOOD DRAGON, WITH
THE WOOD ELEMENT SYMBOLIZING
GROWTH, FLEXIBILITY AND
CREATIVITY. ON EACH OF YOUR
DESKS. THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS HAS PROVIDED A
TRADITIONAL POPULAR DECORATIVE
PLANT TO CELEBRATE THE NEW YEAR.
A CHINESE MONEY, TREE AND NÓ.
THERE IS NÓ MONEY ACTUALLY
INSIDE THERE. UH IN 10 SHUI, THE
PURA AQUATICA MONEY TREE IS A
SYMBOL OF WEALTH, HARMONY AND
GOOD FORTUNE AND IS GIVEN AS A
SYMBOL OF FRIENDSHIP. WE HOPE
THAT THIS GIFT WILL HELP YOU TO
WELCOME IN THE NEW YEAR AND THAT
EVERYONE WILL CELEBRATE THIS
YEAR IN JOY AND HARMONY. HAPPY
LUNAR NEW YEAR AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
ON S¼ R 54. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
MIN. WE HAVE MICROPHONES UP FROM
SENATOR WYNN SENATOR WAHAB
SENATOR BRADFORD, SENATOR D¯ÚI
RAZZO, SENATOR WYNN. MR THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT UM, AND TO
SUPPORT S¼ R 54, WHICH
RECOGNIZES THIS PAST SATURDAY,
FEBRUARY 10TH AS ALSO VIETNAMESE
LUNAR NEW YEAR OR KNOWN AS TED.
IN THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE WORLD. TED CELEBRATES
THE ARRIVAL OF A NEW SPRING
WHERE FAMILIES UNITE, ENJOY EACH
OTHER'S COMPANY. FORGET ABOUT
THE TROUBLES OF THE PREVIOUS
YEAR AND LOOK FORWARD TO A NEW
FEEL, UM, NEWFIELD NEW YEAR FEEL
WITH PROSPERITY, HAPPINESS AND
GOOD HEALTH. TED IS OBSERVED ON
THE FIRST DAY OF THE FIRST MONTH
OF THE VIETNAMESE LUNAR CALENDAR
AND RANGES BETWEEN LATE JANUARY
AND MID FEBRUARY DURING THIS
LUNAR NEW YEAR. FOR US, IT'S
ACTUALLY A THREE DAY CELEBRATION
. SO TODAY IS OUR THIRD YEAR A
THIRD DAY WE ARE THIS AS THE
YEAR OF THE DRAGON. I TOO AM
ALSO BORN OF THE YEAR OF THE
DRAGON. THE DRAGON IS A REVERSE
SYMBOL OF POWER AND THOUGHT TO
BE AMONG THE MOST PROMISING AND
SUCCESSFUL OF THE ZODIAC SIGNS
COMMON TRADITION THAT TAKE PLACE
DURING THE CELEBRATION. LUNAR
NEW YEAR, INCLUDING DISTRIBUTION
OF SMALL RED ENVELOPES WITH
SMALL AMOUNTS OF MONEY, LÀ
LANTERN FESTIVALS LINED FEI
DANCES, FIRE FIREWORKS,
FIRECRACKERS, CLEANING HOMES TO
REMOVE BAD LUCK AND RELIGIOUS
CEREMONIES. I'M SO PROUD TO
SHARE MY FAMILY'S CULTURE AND MY
HERITAGE WITH EVERYONE I MEET,
AND I'M ESPECIALLY PROUD TO
TEACH MY CHILDREN THEIR HERITAGE
, INCLUDING THE TRADITION OF TED
AND LUNAR NEW YEAR. I WOULD LIKE
TO WISH EVERYONE A HAPPY LUNAR
NEW YEAR. DAWSON DO THAT TIME,
CAN YOU YOYA? THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR W. WE NEXT TURN TO
SENATOR WAHAB. THANK YOU. I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S¼
R 54 CELEBRATING LUNAR NEW YEAR,
THE YEAR OF THE WOOD DRAGON. UM
I KNOW MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE STATED THAT THEY'VE BEEN
BORN IN THE YEAR OF THE DRAGON.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO STATE THAT I
WAS BORN IN THE HOUR OF THE
DRAGON LUNAR NEW YEAR IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GATHER WITH
FRIENDS AND FAMILY, CLEANSE
HOMES AND SPIRITS AND LAY
FOUNDATIONS FOR PROSPERITY AND
LUCK IN THE COMING YEAR. I'M
PROUD TO REPRESENT A DISTRICT
THAT IS NOT ONLY MAJORITY ASIAN
BUT ALSO HAS THE LARGEST A API
POPULATION ACROSS THE STATE.
TODAY I WANNA UPLIFT THE
STRENGTH AND RESILIENCY I SEE
ACROSS THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. THE PAST FEW YEARS
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR US ALL
AND IN MANY WAYS CONTINUES TO
CHALLENGE US. LAST YEAR'S
CELEBRATIONS WERE TARNISHED BY
THE SENSELESS VIOLENCE IN
MONTEREY PARK. ONE IN THREE A
API INDIVIDUALS SURVEYED LAST
NOVEMBER REPORTED HAVING BEEN
CONFRONTED WITH RACIAL ABUSE.
AND ACROSS THE A API COMMUNITY.
WE STILL SEE COMPLETE DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES IN HEALTH PAY AND
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS, BUT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN GREATER SOLIDARITY AND
CROSS COMMUNITY AFFIRMATION,
WHICH STRENGTHENS AN EMPOWERS
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THE AMERICAN
DREAM AS WE WELCOME THE YEAR OF
THE DRAGON. I WANT TO WISH YOU
ALL A YEAR FILLED WITH
PROSPERITY, LUCK, HAPPINESS AND
CONTINUED RESILIENCY AND
STRENGTH. HAPPY LUNAR NEW YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE.
NEXT TO SENATOR BRADFORD
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR DIAZO.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS, I
SUPPORT S¼ R 54 RECOGNIZING
FEBRUARY 10TH 2024 IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE LUNAR NEW YEAR.
LUNAR YEAR IS A ANNUAL
CELEBRATION OF STATED OF RENEWAL
, PROSPERITY AND FAMILY. 2024 IS
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR OF
STATED THE WOODEN WOOD DRAGON.
THE WOOD DRAGON IS A SYMBOL OF
STRENGTH AND ABUNDANCE AND IS
FITTING REPRESENTATION OF THE
BILLIONS OF ROUGHLY 6 MILLION
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS, WHO
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME. IT SPEAKS
TO THE ENORMOUS CONTRIBUTION
THAT THE A API COMMUNITY HAS TO
THE SOCIAL, CULTURAL, ECONOMIC
AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF THE
STATE. IT IS FITTING THAT BOTH
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR AND
MAYA ANGELOU WERE BORN IN THE
YEAR OF THE DRAGON. THOSE BORN
AS A DRAGON ARE KNOWN FOR THEIR
STRONG LEADERSHIP AND TIRELESS
WORK OUT EFFORT ETHIC. AND
TAKING ON ALL CHALLENGES AND
OVERCOMING THEM ALL. AS THIS NEW
YEAR BEGINS, AND WE START OUR
WORK IN THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE, LET US EMBRACE
THESE QUALITIES AND OVERCOME THE
CHALLENGES CALIFORNIA FACES
TOGETHER. WE WISH ALL IN THE A
API, OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS A
HAPPY NEW YEAR AND WISH YOU LUCK
AND PROSPERITY TO ALL OF US WITH
THAT I ASKED FOR I VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD. WE'RE
GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR DE RAZO, FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR MENJIVAR SENATOR DURAZZO
. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. ON
BEHALF OF THE LATINO CAUCUS. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF S¼ R 54 AS WE
CELEBRATE THE BEGINNING OF THE
LUNAR NEW YEAR. ACROSS OUR GREAT
AND VERY DIVERSE STATE, MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS AND NATIONALITIES
RING IN THIS IMPORTANT TIME AND
CELEBRATE THE YEAR OF THE WOOD
DRAGON. THIS RICH CULTURAL
HOLIDAY ENCOMPASSES TRADITIONS
THAT ARE ROOTED IN THE HOPE FOR
GOOD FORTUNE PROSPERITY. THEY
INCLUDE FAMILY ORIENTED
GATHERINGS THAT ARE COLORFUL,
CULTURALLY SIGNIFICANT,
ENERGETIC AND FULL OF LIFE. LET
US WORK. HARDER TOWARDS A NEW
YEAR OF FINDING WAYS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO THRIVE. MY
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES INCLUDES SEVERAL
HISTORICALLY RECOGNIZED ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES, INCLUDING
THAI TOWN, KOREATOWN, FILIPINO
TOWN AND CHINATOWN. LATINOS LIVE
WITHIN ALL OF THESE COMMUNITIES.
THEY WORK TOGETHER. THEY LIVE
TOGETHER, THEY GO TO THE
RESTAURANTS TOGETHER. THEY GO TO
SCHOOL TOGETHER, AND THEY
RESPECT EACH OTHER. CULTURE. THE
LATINO CAUCUS JOINS YOU ALL IN
WISHING EVERYONE GOOD HEALTH AND
PROSPERITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR DURAZZO TURN NEXT
TO SENATOR BEN JAAR. FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR WIENER, SENATOR MENJIVAR
. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES I STAND ON BEHALF OF
THE I STAND TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE L GB Tð Q CAUCUS IN
CELEBRATION OF LUNAR NEW YEAR
THE YEAR OF THE DRAGON IN THE
SPIRIT OF THE DRAGON. WE EMBRACE
THE TRANSFORMATIVE ENERGY IT
REPRESENTS IN OUR COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING OUR DIVERSE, RESILIENT
AND POWERFUL API L GB Tð Q PLUS
COMMUNITY WE DRAW INSPIRATION
FROM THE AND A SYMBOLISM TO
ADVOCATE FOR CHANGE, STRENGTH
AND UNITY WITHIN OUR SOCIETY,
AND WE HONOR VISIONARIES LIKE
DOCTOR DAVID HO, A TRAILBLAZER
AND A I Dð S¼ RESEARCH
SYMBOLIZING THE DRAGON'S COURAGE
AND WISDOM, HIS PROFOUND
CONTRIBUTIONS, PARTICULARLY TO
THE L GB Tð PLUS COMMUNITY
UNDERSCORE THE REMARKABLE
POTENTIAL WITHIN US ALL TO
AFFECT TRANSFORMATIVE CHANGE.
THE CELEBRATION IS A TESTAMENT
TO THE RICH TAPESTRY OF
TRADITIONS THAT THE API
COMMUNITY BRINGS TO CALIFORNIA
AND I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR I
VOTE IN SR 54. THANK YOU,
SENATOR MANAR, SENATOR WEINER.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE
AS CO-CHAIR OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS. UH AND ALSO AS,
UH, SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS, UM,
ONE OF THE LARGEST, UH, API
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE, NEARLY
36% OF OUR DISTRICT. UH, IS API,
UH TO, UH, WISH A VERY HAPPY
LUNAR NEW YEAR. UH, TO OUR
NEIGHBORS, UH, AND, UH, TO
REALLY JUST STRESS THAT YES,
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME REAL
CHALLENGES. FOR OUR API
COMMUNITIES AROUND, UH, API HEAT
OR ON VIOLENCE, AND WE'VE HAD,
UH, SOME TERRIBLE ATTACKS,
PARTICULARLY ON, UH, OUR API
SENIORS AND SAN FRANCISCO AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE BAY AREA. SO
MANY CHALLENGES, BUT, UM, WHAT I
SEE ON A DAILY BASIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY, UH, BEAUTIFUL ARRAY
OF COMMUNITIES. UH THAT AND JUST
INCREDIBLE JOY AND LOVE. UH, ON
SATURDAY, I WAS IN CHINATOWN FOR
DAY LONG CELEBRATION OF LUNAR
NEW YEAR. UH AND IT WAS JUST
INCREDIBLY JOYOUS. UH AND SO I'M
VERY PROUD, UH, TO REPRESENT, UH
UH, THIS COMMUNITY. I'M PROUD
THAT CALIFORNIA, UH, REALLY IS
EMBRACING AND LIFTING UP OUR API
NEIGHBORS AND I WISH EVERYONE
HAPPY NEW YEAR UH SUNNY FLO
CONGE FOY. SENATOR WEINER.
CULTIVATE, HAVING CEASED.
SENATOR MEN YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. UH MR PRESIDENT. I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
STRONG SUPPORT TODAY FOR LU█N E,
AS WELL AS FOR THE A API
COMMUNITY, GENERALLY THROUGHOUT
THEIR DISTRICTS AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. UH, I ALSO WANT TO
APOLOGIZE TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GARDEN GROVE FOR MY BUTCHERING
OF THE VIETNAMESE LUNAR NEW YEAR
GREETING. I'LL GET IT RIGHT. ONE
OF THESE DAYS. I THINK I GOT THE
CANTONESE AND KOREAN. ALL RIGHT.
UH AND I WANNA JUST POINT OUT
THAT RED IS THE TRADITIONAL
COLOR OF LUNAR NEW YEAR, WHICH
IS WHY I'M WEARING MY WIFE'S
FAVORITE JACKET TODAY, UH OR AT
LEAST FAVOR JACKET. IT
SYMBOLIZES GOOD FORTUNE AND JOY.
UH, FINALLY, JUST ONE BEFORE
CLOSING. I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT I WAS INCORRECT IN STATING
THAT THERE'S NÓ MONEY IN YOUR
MONEY TREE. THERE'S ACTUALLY A
PENNY IN THERE FOR GOOD LUCK.
SO, UH, WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU I VOTE.
SENATOR MIN. THANK YOU FOR
CLEARING THE RECORD. AND FOR
WEARING THAT BEAUTIFUL JACKET
TODAY, SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN OF AYE, ARCHULETTA.
HIY ASHBY. AYE, ATKINS. I BECKER
AYE, BLAKESPEAR. HØI BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO. I HIY DALLY. DODD. AY
TORAZO I EGM. UH, GLASER. HIY
GONZALEZ, A GROVE? I HURTADO. I.
JONES. I, LAIRD. I LEMON? I
MCGUIRE AYE, MAJOR. I MEAN,
NEWMAN. I WIN. HØI NILO. I, A
JOE OAK VIDEO. FORTINO AYE,
ROCK. I RUBIO SARTO. I. SKINNER.
HØI SMALL QUAVERS. STERN. HØI
UMBERG. I WILL HAVE HØI WIENER.
AYE. WELL, AYE. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE RULE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALL MEN? AYE. PA.
RUBIO. SMALL QUAVERS. A VOTE OF
35 TO 0. THE RESOLUTIONS ADOPTED
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. THIS IS S¼ R
64. SENATOR LAIRD IS PREPARED,
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION 64 BY SENATOR LAIRD
RELATIVE TO THE ELECTION OF
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON RULES, SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR PRESIDENT, UH,
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION 64, WHICH WILL ADD
THE SENATOR FROM STOCKTON AND
THE SENATOR FROM SANTEE TO THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. UH I
WANT TO PERSONALLY. THANK UH THE
SENATORS FROM LOS ANGELES. AND
YOU èC A FOR THEIR, UH, RECENT
SERVICE ON THE SENATE. UH,
RULES. COMMITTEE IT WAS AND
NEITHER ONE IS HERE. SO I WILL,
UH, IN ADDITION, THANK THEM
PERSONALLY WHEN I NEXT, SEE THEM
, UM, I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE NEW ELECTED SENATORS AS
WELL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
I VOTE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS RESOLUTION, IT IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. THAT OBJECTIONS AYS 35 NÓ
ZERO, THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO PHI
ITEM NUMBER NINE. THIS IS S¼ R
65, SENATOR GONZALEZ. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. IN A RESOLUTION 65
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO
THE STANDING RULES OF THE SENATE
FOR THE 2020 THREE 2024 REGULAR
SESSION. SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION 65,
WHICH AMENDS THE RULES OF THE
SENATE TO ADD TO LOCAL ADD THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEES. CURRENTLY
THESE TWO SUBJECT AREAS ARE
UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. PRIOR TO 2011, THE
SENATE HAD A SEPARATE LOCAL
GOVERNANCE AND REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE. SO S¼ R 65
SIMPLY REVERTS BACK TO THE
PREVIOUS ORGANIZATION OF THESE
SUBJECT AREAS BY ESTABLISHING
TWO DIFFERENT COMMITTEES. UH,
HAVING TWO DISTINCT COMMITTEES
WILL ENSURE THAT THESE ISSUES
ARE THOROUGHLY EXAMINED AND
DISCUSSED BY SENATORS AND THE
PUBLIC. MOST IMPORTANTLY, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON S¼ R 65. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GONZALEZ. ANY DISCUSSION OR ON
THIS RESOLUTION. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THERE'S AN
OBJECTION. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I RATHER
HØI ARCHULETA. I ASHBY. I,
ATKINS I BECKER AYE, BLAKESPEAR.
UH, BRADFORD. HIY CABALLERO. UH,
CORTESI. I DALLY. I DO. I DO.
RAO HØI EGM. I GLASER. AYE,
GONZALEZ. GROWTH. I HURTADO. HØI
JONES. I LAIRD. I THE AYE,
MCGUIRE. HØI M JAR. I MEAN, IY
NEWMAN. I WIN. AYE, NILO. I, A
èC B¢O VIDEO. ARGENTINO. AYE,
RO. I RUBIO. THEY ARE TO HIY
SKINNER. I SMALL QUAVERS STERN.
I UMBERG. AYE, WAHAB. AYE,
WIENER. I WILL. NÓ MHM. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN
PATROL BOAT. DEAL. RUBIO. MORE
CUEVAS. A VOTE OF 34 TO 1. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS
THE TIME TO ADDRESS A IN
MEMORIES. ON A FIRST RECOGNIZED
SENATOR NEWMAN. PLEASE GIVE
SENATOR NEWMAN YOUR ATTENTION
MEMBERS. UH, THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I, I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY. OF LANCE LARSON, A
LOVING HUSBAND AND FATHER.
DENTIST UH AND FAMOUSLY THE
RIGHTFUL WINNER OF ONE OF THE
MOST CONTROVERSIAL GOLD MEDALS
IN OLYMPIC SWIMMING HISTORY, WHO
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY 19TH AT
THE AGE OF 83. LANCE MELVIN
LARSON WAS BORN IN 1940, THE SON
OF MONTEREY PARK DAIRY FARMERS A
TRUE PRODUCT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, WITH ITS SUNNY
SKIES, BALMY WEATHER AND BEACH
BOY CULTURE. IT SAID THAT LANCE
TO SWIMMING IS A MEANS OF
WASHING OFF THE DIRT AND GRIME
THAT COMES WITH RUNNING THE
DAIRIES THAT ONCE STARTED THE
REGION'S ROLLING HILLS. WHILE HE
MAY NOT HAVE REALIZED IT AT THE
TIME, LANCE'S GRAVITATIONAL
SWIMMING WOULD NOT ONLY REDEFINE
THE LIMITS OF THE SPORT, BUT
WHAT INDELIBLY SHAPE THE
EVOLUTION OF MODERN COMPETITIVE
SWIMMING AS WE KNOW IT LAND.
LARSON'S REMARKABLE SWIMMING
CAREER BEGAN AT EL MONTE HIGH
SCHOOL, WHERE HE HAD THE
DISTINCTION OF BECOMING THE
FIRST HIGH SCHOOL SWIMMER TO
COMPLETE THE 100 YARD FREESTYLE
IN LESS THAN 50 SECONDS, LANCE
WOULD CONTINUE TO HONE HIS
ABILITIES. UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, WHERE HE
EARNED TWO  N èC A TITLES, SIX
TIME ALL AMERICAN HONORS AND
WHERE HE BECAME THE FIRST KNOWN
MAN TO BREAK THE ONE MINUTE
BARRIER IN THE 100 M BUTTERFLY,
AS WELL AS THE FIRST TO COMPLETE
THE 200 M INDIVIDUAL MEDLEY IN
UNDER TWO MINUTES AND 25 SECONDS
. BY THE TIME LANCE LARSON
ARRIVED IN ROME IN 1960 AS A
MEMBER OF THE U S¼ MEN'S OLYMPIC
SWIM TEAM, HE WAS ALREADY THE
HOLDER OF NOT ONE BUT TWO WORLD
RECORDS, FIRMLY ESTABLISHING THE
YOUNG AMERICAN AS AMONG THE
FAVORITES TO UNSEAT THE
DEFENDING AUSTRALIANS, A
PERENNIAL SWIMMING POWERHOUSE.
IN THOSE DAYS IN THE 100 M
FREESTYLE. THE 100 M FREESTYLE
WAS IN FACT, A MATCHUP THAT WAS
SO ANTICIPATED THAT WHEN IT CAME
TIME FOR THE EVENT, THE
STADIUM'S LIGHTS WERE DIMMED FOR
DRAMATIC EFFECT. AT THE START,
THE SWIMMERS DOVE OFF THE BLOCKS
AND INTO THE WATER, WITH LANCE
PULLING JUST AHEAD ALONGSIDE
AUSTRALIANS, JOHN DE WIT AS THE
CROWD WATCHED BREATHLESSLY.
NEITHER MAN COULD BREAK AWAY
FROM THE OTHER. WITH 15 M STILL
REMAINING, THE TWO LEAD SWIMMERS
APPEAR TO BE MATCHING EACH
OTHER'S STROKES EXACTLY AND AS
THEY CONVERGE AT THE WALL, ANY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO WAS
VISUALLY IMP. ACCEPT THIS ALL
TOOK PLACE IN THE ERA BEFORE
PRECISION TIMING, ACCORDING TO
THE OFFICIAL TIMER STOPWATCHES.
THE AUSTRALIAN'S TIME WAS 55.2
SECONDS WITH THE AMERICAN 1/10
OF A SECOND FASTER AT 55.1
SECONDS, ACCORDING TO THOSE
STOPWATCHES LANCE LARSON OF THE
U S¼ A WAS BY ALL INDICATIONS
THE OLYMPIC WINNER BUT THEN IN
AN UNPRECEDENTED AND HUGELY
CONTROVERSIAL MOVE, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE INTERNATIONAL
SWIMMING FEDERATION INTERVENE
PERSONALLY, NOT ONLY OVERRULING
THE STOPWATCHES BUT
RETROACTIVELY, ADDING AND SECOND
TO LANCE LARSON'S OFFICIAL TIME
AND UNILATERALLY DECLARING THE
AUSTRALIAN JOHN DEWITT, THE
WINNER THAT RACE LIVES ON IN THE
HISTORY BOOKS AS WHAT THE
INTERNATIONAL OLYMPIC COMMITTEE
ITSELF CALLS THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL OLYMPIC SWIM RACE
EVER. THE OUTCRY WOULD
SUBSEQUENTLY ENSUED OVER LANCE
LARSON'S STOLEN GOLD WOULD
ULTIMATELY FORCE THE I Ó èC TO
ADOPT ELECTRONIC TOUCH PADS FOR
MORE PRECISE TIMING AND
EVOLUTION OF THE SPORT THAT
CONTINUES TO THIS DAY. HIS
STOLEN GOLD IN THE 100 FREESTYLE
NOTWITHSTANDING, LANCE LARSON
WOULD STILL RETURN TO
CALIFORNIA. A GOLD MEDALIST,
HAVING COMBINED WITH HIS
TEAMMATES TO SAY YET ANOTHER
WORLD RECORD IN THE FOUR BY 100
MEDLEY, UH, RELAY BUT BEFORE
THAT, AND IN KEEPING WITH HIS
SUNNY, SO CALLED DEMEANOR AND
FUN LOVING NATURE, ALL OF THE
ACRIMONY SURROUNDING HIS
CONTESTED MEDAL NOT ONLY DID NOT
TARNISH LANCE'S EXPERIENCE AS A
YOUNG OLYMPIAN IN ITALY AS HE
TRAVELED THE COUNTRY PRIOR PRIOR
TO FLYING HOME, IT ALSO GOT HIM
AN UNTOLD NUMBER OF FREE DRINKS.
LANCE LAWSON'S PROLIFIC
CONTRIBUTION TO THE SPORT,
HAVING SET 12 NATIONAL AND FIVE
WORLD SWIMMING RECORDS CEMENTED
HIS LEGACY AS ONE OF THE MOST
REVERED AND ICONIC ATHLETES IN
CALIFORNIA'S SPORTING HISTORY
AND HIS POST SWIMMING CAREER.
LANCE LARSON WOULD GO ON TO
GRADUATE FROM U S¼ èC IN 1962
AND EARN HIS DENTAL DEGREE FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF THE PACIFIC IN
1964. IN KEEPING WITH HIS
AFFINITY FOR WATER, LANCE
ENLISTED IN THE UNITED STATES
NAVY DENTAL CORPS, SUBSEQUENTLY
OPENING UP HIS OWN DENTAL
PRACTICE IN THE CITY OF ORANGE
UPON THE COMPLETION OF HIS
MILITARY SERVICE, LANCE WAS
ABOVE ALL ELSE. THEY DEVOTED
HUSBAND AND FATHER. HE HAS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE, SHERRI.
FOUR SONS, TWO DAUGHTERS, THREE
STEPDAUGHTERS AND MANY MANY
GRANDCHILDREN. ONE OF HIS SONS,
LANCE JUNIOR, WHO SERVES AS THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS AT THE
ORANGE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY, IS HERE WITH US IN
THE GALLERY THIS AFTERNOON. WE
OFFER OUR CONDOLENCES TO YOU AND
YOUR WHOLE FAMILY. UH AND I ASK
THAT THE SENATE CHAIR AND LANCE
LARSON'S MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEWMAN ON THIS ITEM,
SENATOR MIN. UH, THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, UH, AND COLLEAGUES. I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM,
UH, FULLERTON FOR ADJOURNING IN
MEMORY OF MR LARSON. UH, I THANK
MY COLLEAGUE APTLY EXPRESSED THE
HISTORY OF HIS GREAT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, INCLUDING THE
FACT THAT HE WAS INDEED ROBBED.
ROBBED HE WAS ROBBED, BUT HE
WENT ON TO A TREMENDOUS LIFE.
AND I JUST WANT TO NOTE UH, THAT
THAT HE LIVED A FULL LIFE DYING
AT THE AGE OF 83 IN THE CITY OF
ORANGE AND, UM, SET A REAL, I
THINK BENCHMARK FOR SO MANY
ATHLETES. UH OF COURSE. ORANGE
COUNTY IS KNOWN FOR ALL THE
SWIMMERS THAT HAVE COME OUT OF
OUR RANKS, AND CERTAINLY HE WAS
ONE OF THE PIONEERS IN THIS
REGARD. SO I ALSO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. M UH, SENATOR
LARSON'S SON. WE WELCOME HERE.
YOU HERE TO THE SENATE CHAMBERS.
OUR CONDOLENCE TO YOU, YOUR
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. SENATOR
NEWMAN. IF YOU BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE SENATE
JOURNAL. NEXT UP MEMBERS. FOR AN
ADJOURNING MEMORY, SENATOR NILO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
VICE PRES PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF SHARON
RUFFNER, A VERY DISTINGUISHED
COMMUNITY LEADER AND DEVOTED.
VERY DEVOTED VOLUNTEER IN THE
CARMICHAEL AREA AND BEYOND,
WHOSE GOOD DEEDS EARNED HER THE
RESPECT AND ADMIRATION OF HER
COLLEAGUES AND THE MANY
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE LIVES SHE
TOUCHED. SHARON WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN SACRAMENTO, GRADUATED
FROM EL CAMINO HIGH SCHOOL,
WHERE SHE EXCELLED IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE AND AFTER GRADUATION,
ACCEPTED A POSITION WITH THE SAN
JUAN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
ITS TECHNOLOGY SERVICES SERVICES
DEPARTMENT. HERE SHE MASTERED
ELECTRONIC PROCESSING AND LATER
TRAINED ADMINISTRATORS, CLERICAL
WORKERS AND TEACHERS IN HER
CHARACTERISTIC STYLE AND
PATIENCE, ALWAYS PUTTING
STUDENTS FIRST. AFTER RETIRING
IN 2014 FOLLOWING A 37 YEAR
CAREER WITH THE SAN JUAN SCHOOL
DISTRICT. SHE CONTINUED TEACHING
YOGA AND EXERCISE CLASSES AND
DEDICATING HER TIME TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE. AND SERVING AS CO
PRESIDENT OF THE KIWANIS CLUB OF
CARMICHAEL, AND AT THE SAME, AND
AT THE TIME OF HER PASSING, SHE
HELD THE POSITION AS PRESIDENT
OF THE CARMICHAEL PARKS
FOUNDATION. THE EXTRAORDINARY
NUMBER OF VOLUNTEER PROJECTS SHE
ORCHESTRATED, LED THE COMMUNITY
TO INITIATE A SHARON RUFFNER
COMMUNITY SERVICE DAY TO HONOR
HER EFFORTS. SHARON WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR HER COMPASSION,
FRIENDLINESS AND SENSE OF HUMOR.
SHE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO BETTER
HER COMMUNITY AND WAS RECOGNIZED
FOR HER SERVICE BY MANY
ORGANIZATIONS. FOR THOSE WHO
KNEW HER. SHE WILL ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED AS A SYMBOL OF
PERPETUAL SUNLIGHT. SHARON
LEAVES TO MOURN HER PASSING AND
CELEBRATE HER LEGACY. HER
HUSBAND, BOB, A MEMBER OF OUR
SENATE FAMILY, AND HERE WITH US
TODAY, HER SISTER IN LAW ROBIN,
HER NIECE AND FOUR NEPHEWS AND
MANY, MANY CLOSE FRIENDS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING HER MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND THE LEGACY
OF A DISTINGUISHED AND CARING
INDIVIDUAL WHO LIVED LIVED LIFE
TO THE FULLEST AND WHOSE SPIRIT
WILL FOREVER BE IN THE HEARTS
AND MEMORIES OF HER LOVED ONES.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NILO. THE
SENATE EXTENDS THEIR CONDOLENCES
TO THE FRIENDS AND FAMILY OF
SHARON RUFFNER. IF THERE ARE NÓ
OTHER BUSINESS BEFORE THE
SENATE, UH, SENATOR MAGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT THANK YOU
FOR THE WONDERFUL CEREMONY OF
THE IRVINE FOUNDATION. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
FRIDAY. FEBRUARY 16TH 2024 AT 9
A.M. IN ANTICIPATION OF THE
UPCOMING THREEDAY WEEKEND.
UNFORTUNATE NIGHT FOR 49ER FANS.
UH, BUT WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO BE
FAITHFUL. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE 30 PM, AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE PLACED. WE WILL
RECONVENE FRIDAY AT 9 A.M.